When it comes to Star Wars, there are a bunch
of theories out there in the void known as
the internet.
Some are straight up crazy, some seem entirely
credible.
One of the most popular topics is concerning
who Rey is, the scavenger turned Jedi that
lead the way in the force awakens.
So who is she?
Well one such theory may blow your mind if
it turns out to be true.
Give us a like if you think anyone of these
five reasons why we think Rey might just be
Darth Vader reincarnated can happen!
Dreamworld
Much like Anakin Skywalker before her, Rey
has shown to be so in tuned with the Force
that she possesses the ability to peak into
the past as well as the future.
Anakin saw flashes of pain and suffering when
concerning those he loved most, namely his
mother Shmi and his wife Padme.
Rey demonstrated a similar ability when she
touched Anakin’s saber in the force awakens,
getting glimpses at both the past, including
a peak into cloud city where Vader revealed
to Luke his lineage, which may or may not
be Vader’s own memory
of the event.
She may also get a glimpse into the future,
much as Anakin did, where she witness the
Knights of Ren finishing up a massacre on
a rainy planet.
While we don’t know for sure that it was
the future, we do know that this scene is
not Luke’s academy massacre.
Force Ghost 2.0
Another point that fans have been quick to
point out is that Rey shares some facial similarities
to that of Shmi Skywalker, Anakin’s mother
who was killed by sand people in episode 2.
Could a reincarnated Anakin adopt a look that
would harken back to his beloved mother?
And why would the force wait so long to bring
Anakin back as Rey?
The first force ghost was qui gon jinn, and
it took him almost 10 years to manifest himself
through the force.
Obi wan shows himself to Luke after 3 (but
being very vocal from the get go) and Yoda
took another year.
So if Rey is the next step, going beyond force
ghosts and restarting the prophecy, the time
to learn such a feat may take decades.
The Force is strong in my family…
Despite having no formal training as of episode
7, Rey has shown she is quite powerful in
the force, illustrating accelerated feats
of learning and proficiency.
In a matter of days, she has learned and understood
saber combat, besting Kylo Ren, the force
grab when reaching for the saber in her Excalibur
moment and mastering the Jedi mind trick after
3 tries, with no prior knowledge that it was
even a technique prior to that.
Maybe she’s born that way?
Much like Anakin, she is also a gifted pilot
and mechanic.
The prophecy of the chosen one
One of the main reasons is the chosen one
prophecy that was introduced in the prequel
trilogy.
In it, it said a figure would rise up and
bring balance to the force.
Anakin did eventually do this, but not before
almost completely wiping the Jedi off the
map.
So what if the force is giving the Skywalker
another chance via reincarnation to fulfil
the prophecy with the threat of the first
order, snoke and the knights of ren growing
ever more darker.
It calls to you…
Perhaps the most obvious point of contention
for this theory is that the saber straight
up calls to Rey.
Bear in mind that this saber is not Luke Skywalker’s
but in fact his father’s, Anakin’s.
Luke merely adopted it before crafting his
own green one in return of the Jedi.
So with a powerful connection between Rey
and Anakin being established, could the saber
be reaching out to its former master, sensing
a familiar presence in the force nearby and
latching over to it?
Kylo is after all Vader’s grandson yet the
saber rejected him and went to Rey, and that
saber helped kill the younglings so it’s
seen some better days.
So there you have it, some chin scratching
ideas to consider while we await the next
entry in the Star Wars franchise.
Do you agree with this theory or think it’s
downright crazy?
What other theories have you heard of concerning
Rey?
Let us know in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe for more videos like this one
coming soon!